die Bundesregierung ist im Dauerstreit
und der Bundeskanzler im Umfragetief und
die SPD wird davon massiv beschädigt
trotzdem hört man von den
spd-parteivorsitzenden kaum Kritik diese
Woche rüffelte Lars klingenball einmal
kurz in Richtung Ampel aber wäre er auch
bereits sich mit seinem eigenen
Bundeskanzler anzulegen und wie lange
will er eigentlich dem Abstieg der
Sozialdemokraten noch zuschauen das
frage ich heute den spd-ko-vorsitzenden
Lars Klingbeil in seinem Heimatort
Münster herzlich willkommen zum ZDF
sommerinterview
[Musik]
hallo klingwald hallo ich grüße Sie
herzlich willkommen beim ZDF
sommerinterview herzlich willkommen
meine Heimatstadt das ist genau ihre
heimatmonster auch ihr Wahlkreis weil es
zugleich und man kann vieles darüber
erzählen sie haben in einem Podcast mal
erzählt wie die Kindheit in der Nähe
eines Truppenübungsplatzes war dass sie
hier
genau dreimal die Woche auch von
Schießübungen aus dem Schlaf gerissen
worden etc sie selbst sind aus einer
bundeswehr-familie sie haben den
Kriegsdienst verweigert wenn ich mir
jetzt angucke wie sie heute über
Sicherheitspolitik reden frage ich
musste es so kommen dass ausgerechnet
sie dann der Parteivorsitzende werden
der den Pazifismus in der SPD endgültig
an den Rand drängt die spd-pazifistische
Partei haben aber wir sind immer
kritisch gewesen wir diskutieren
kritisch auch über den Einsatz von
Militär wir wissen es gibt auch andere
Möglichkeiten über die wir reden müssen
und wir machen uns das nicht leicht und
das ist auch richtig und an dieser
Tradition hat sich auch als
SPD-Vorsitzender fest aber hier sind wir
stolz darauf dass wir auch die
ukrainischen Soldaten an den Leopard 2
panz ausbilden in meiner Heimatstadt und
auch dafür steht die SPD dass wir an der
Seite der Ukraine stehen dass wir
solidarisch sind und dass wir Sie
unterstützen
sie führen Koalition nennt die Ampel
möchte gerne Tempo machen mit einem
Ausbau unter anderem von Infrastruktur
jetzt sind ausgerechnet hier bei ihnen
im Wahlkreis so dass sie gegen einen ein
großes schienenausbauprojekt der
Bundesbahn sind sie lachen schon die
Details mal beiseite gelassen
es gibt immer ein Für und Wieder sind
sie nicht mit dieser Haltung das
Sinnbild des Problems warum ist so
langsam voran geht bei solchen
Ausbauprojekt gehen diese diese
Möglichkeit müssen sie mir lassen wir
haben mit der Bahn mit dem Land
Niedersachsen mit dem
Bundesverkehrsministerium hier vor Ort
ein Jahr lang knapp diskutiert alle
BürgerInnen und Bürgermeister Landräte
wir haben ein Kompromiss gefunden der
diese Region viel viel stärker belastet
als seine Neubautrasse das haben wir in
den Koalitionsvertrag reingeschrieben
sowohl im Land als auch im Bund davon
rückt die Bahn jetzt ab das habe ich
kritisiert ich bin dafür dass wir die
Bahn massiv ausbauen aber ich bin auch
für Varianten die die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger akzeptieren wo sie dabei sind wo
sie die Belastung auch auf sich nehmen
und da muss die Bahn sichern Versprechen
halten und nicht der Rest kann man viel
über Reformen streiten es gibt da immer
viele Widerstände das sieht die Ampel
momentan auch in der fährt das wieder
wir reden gleich in unserem Set weiter
darüber freu mich drauf hier geht's lang
[Musik]
Herr klingen weil das war eine spannende
Woche für Sie ihnen ist diese Woche mal
die Hutschnur geplatzt in Richtung Ampel
sie haben gesagt sie seien fassungslos
darüber dass dort wieder so gestritten
wird statt für Sicherheit Ordnung und
Stabilität zu sorgen und sie haben
praktisch gesagt damit muss jetzt
langsam mal Schluss sein das lässt sie
eigentlich glauben dass irgendjemand im
Kabinett auf sie hört
es ist das richtige es ist das richtige
dass alle sich zusammenreißen dass man
sich um die Dinge kümmert die die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesem Land
bewegen die helfen das Land
voranzubringen und
ich hatte eigentlich ich hatte
eigentlich gehofft dass über den Sommer
alle noch mal reflektiert haben was mit
dem heizungsgesetz auch vor der
Sommerpause passiert ist da haben wir
selbst
dazu beigetragen dass Verunsicherung in
der Bevölkerung gestiegen ist das
Unklarheit da war das Unzufriedenheit
doch gewachsen ist und ich meine jeder
der am Kabinettstisch sitzt das ist ja
ein Privileg auch diesen tollen Land
dient zu dürfen indem man Ministerin
oder Minister ist und ich erwarte von
jedem dass man auch dann den Pflichten
nachgeht und dass man dazu beiträgt und
ich gehe schon davon aus dass das alle
auch gehört haben und dass wir jetzt
sehr schnell zu einer Einigung kommen
sowohl was die Frage der
wirtschaftlichen Hilfen angeht da warten
die unternehmerinnenunternehmen drauf da
warten die Gewerkschaften und die
Beschäftigten drauf als auch bei der
Frage der Kindergrundsicherung das ist
ja kein entweder oder sondern es geht um
beides und ich erwarte dass das jetzt
sehr schnell in der Regierung umgesetzt
wird
allerdings hat es auch schon jemand
anders versucht nämlich Urlaub Scholz
der hat an dem Morgen bevor dann der
Blockade kam noch mal im 6 augengespräch
mit dieser Pause und Christian Lindner
gesprochen vergeblich kann er da nicht
schlichten oder will er nicht
erstmal hat der Kanzler ja sowohl mit
Robert Habeck als auch mit Christian
Lindner geredet und beide haben
signalisiert das wachstumschancengesetz
kann ins Kabinett das ist geeint dann
ist es in letzter Sekunde gestoppt
worden ich kann das bis heute nicht
nachvollziehen aber es ist ja richtig
dass wir auch sehr lange in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen drüber
gesprochen haben dass das eine Regierung
ist bei der es nicht dieses Koch
kellnerverhältnis gibt nicht den Kanzler
der andauernd auf den Tisch haut und
rumbrüllt sondern das ist eine Koalition
auf Augenhöhe ist und Augenhöhe heißt
Eigenverantwortung und es muss einfach
Schluss damit sein dass man sich um sich
selbst dreht es muss darum gehen dass
wir die Dinge anpacken die für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wichtig sind in
diesem Land und das ist sowohl die Frage
der wirtschaftlichen Hilfe als auch die
Frage der Kindergrundsicherung und noch
mal meine Erwartung ist dass es diesen
Monat noch entschieden sind kein
Verhältnis dann muss man sich ja
untereinander einigen und Sie haben
immer wieder gesagt die SPD soll sich
dann nicht in Streit verwickeln lassen
Jürgen Trittin sagt im Prinzip stimmt
doch gar nicht tun sie ja denn der
Bundeskanzler Zitat
im Zweifel ist die SPD immer auf der
Seite der FDP der Bundeskanzler würde
sich da quasi immer auf die Seite der
FDP schlagen müssen sie da nicht auch
feststellen da ist was dran ein falsche
Geschichten werden nicht dadurch richtig
dass man sie oft erzählt also kann ich
jetzt genug Beispiele ich kann Ihnen
jetzt genug Beispiele nennen und ich
kann genug Beispiele nennen zum Beispiel
die Frage Atomausstieg zum Beispiel die
Frage der Gast und Strompreis Bremse zum
Beispiel die Frage der übergewinn
Abschöpfung das sind alles Dinge kann
ich jetzt hier glaube ich erzählen wo
ich in internen Gesprächen nicht auf
Jubel und Begeisterung beim Liberalen
Koalitionspartner gestoßen bin aber das
haben wir intern geklärt und ich habe
eine feste Überzeugung dass eine
Koalition wo die ganze Zeit öffentlich
auch vermessen wird wer es Gewinner wer
ist Verlierer wer hat Millimeter oder
Meter Gewinne dieses mathematisch
auseinander rechnen wird das ist das
interessiert doch kein wir müssen die
Dinge lösen die gerade auf Tisch liegen
da geht's um die wirtschaftliche Lage da
geht's um das soziale Gefüge da geht's
um die geopolitische internationale
Situation und es wird immer mal
Entscheidungen geben wo man mit dem
einen oder anderen mehr sym die
vielleicht hat aber darum geht es doch
nicht in der Koalition wir müssen
geräuschlos daran arbeiten dass das Land
vorankommt und das erwarte ich heute
tatsächlich hat das Auswirkungen wenn es
nicht geräuschlos läuft das Ansehen der
Ampel ist extrem ramponiert 58 Prozent
der Befragten wir uns im Politbarometer
sagen die Ampel macht ihre Arbeit eher
schlecht satte 83 Prozent sagen bei der
Lösung von Problemen komme sie zurzeit
eher nicht voran wie sehr das auch der
SPD schadet das zeigt uns jetzt Thomas
Reichert mal in 60 Sekunden
am Abend da ist die SPD die
Bundestagswahl gewann gab Olaf Scholz
ein Versprechen ich bin sicher die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden sich auch
nachträglich über ihre Entscheidung
freuen die sie getroffen haben als sie
die SPD gewählt haben das Versprechen
gilt auch tatsächlich scheint sich immer
weniger Bürger über die SPD zu freuen
ihre Umfragewerte sind abgestürzt auf
zuletzt 19% im Ampel Streit hält sich
die Kanzlerpartei zwar zurück schaden
tut er ihr genauso
denn mit einem Scholz der sich aus allem
raushält bleibt unklar wo die SPD steht
wohin die angebliche
fortschrittskoalition marschiert die
Parteien nimmt es duldend hin keine
Aufstände wie früher gegen den eigenen
Kanzler die SPD hofft auf ein Wunder wie
beim letzten Mal als sie aus einem
tiefen Tal als kurz vor der Wahl ganz
nach oben schoss die bittere Wahrheit
für die SPD aber könnte sein dass 2021
eine Ausnahme bleibt und die
Kanzlerpartei weiter so schwach wie ihre
aktuellen Umfragewerte für Sie als
Parteivorsitzender sicherlich eine
beunruhigende Situation sie haben ja
auch gerade noch mal klar gemacht wie
groß ihre Sorgen da sind sie haben im
Mai schon mal gesagt der heizungsstreit
habe zu einer wahnsinnigen
Verunsicherung geführt und treibe die
Menschen in die Arme der AFD und
tatsächlich liegt die SPD jetzt seit
Wochen in Umfragen hinter der AFD die
können Sie das denn als
Parteivorsitzender laufen lassen und
quasi nur appellieren das hat nichts mit
laufen lassen zu tun deswegen ich will
auch nur eine Sache einordnen mir sind
gerade in einer historischen
Umbruchphase wenn ich mir angucke was
geopolitisch sicherheitspolitisch mit
dem Krieg mitten in Europa passiert wenn
ich mir anschaue wie die Welt sich
gerade neu sortiert wenn ich anschaue
dass diese Aufbruch in die klimaneutrale
Wirtschaft uns allen wahnsinnig viel
abverlangt das ist ein historische Phase
auf die wir 2030 Jahren zurückgucken und
da gehen wir du können jetzt haben sie
recht dieser Kampf gegen die AFD ist das
was uns fordert und den führen wir als
sozialdemokratern Sozialdemokraten das
liegt schon in unserer DNA wir haben in
unserer 160-jährigen Geschichte nun
wirklich unter rechtsextreme und Nazis
gelitten deswegen ist das
selbstverständlich für uns aber was
nicht hilft ist das jetzt panisch werden
wir müssen die Alltagsprobleme der
Menschen lösen das ist das was uns
umtreibt wohnen die Frage wie kann
Klimaneutralität gelingen die Frage wie
muss der Sozialstaat funktionieren wie
kann die Wirtschaft gestärkt werden wir
müssen eine Politik machen die auf
Augenhöhe begegnet und wir müssen
präsent werden das ist alles das gegen
die AFD genau sie sollten nicht panisch
werden würde mich sehr interessieren wie
sie denn da gerade auf das gucken was in
Sachen Flüchtlingspolitik da passiert
denn da haben erst die SPD-Bürgermeister
Alarm vorgeschlagen haben gesagt das ist
zu viel dann hat Nancy Phaser
bundesinnenministerin die gleichzeitig
im hessenwahlkampf steht weil sie dort
Ministerpräsidentin werden will auf eine
härtere Gangart bei der Ausweisung von
geflüchteten umgestellt hat sie da auf
den Druck der Basis reagiert ist das
Panik oder ist das so gewollt das ist
eine Herausforderung die wir
zweifelsohne haben dass wir mit
steigenden migrationszahlen umgehen
müssen als Land als Europa und wissen
sie das was Regierung davor nicht
geschafft haben hier anzupacken ich lese
auch gerade in diesen Tagen das ist
viele kluge Ratschläge gibt von Leuten
die lange Verantwortung getragen aber es
ist richtig was nennt sie selber macht
ist es richtig was Olaf Scholz mit den
Ministerpräsidenten von Union von Grün
von SPD abgestimmt hat und es ist
richtig dass wir das jetzt umsetzen auf
der einen Seite öffnen wir das Land und
machen Deutschland zu einem wirklichen
Einwanderungsland was und stark macht
auf der anderen Seite sorgen wird
europäisch dafür dass Menschen die nicht
hier bleiben können schneller das Land
wieder verlassen es ist ein gut es ist
eine Mischung aus Humanität und völliger
Klarheit auch in der Konsequenz und da
hatten sie die voll Unterstützung
Parteivorstand hat das jetzt noch mal
eine große Mehrheit festgestellt ihr
Vorsitzender Vorgänger im Parteivorsitz
auch ist die Frage Sigmar Gabriel hat
gerade zum Thema Bootsflüchtlinge auf
dem Mittelmeer folgendes gesagt dass
zitiere ich mal wir müssen diese Leute
dann allesamt in das Land zurückbringen
wo ihr Schiff gestartet ist wie viel
Anbiederung an die AFD Wähler steckt da
drin mein Stil ist keine Anbiederung an
die AFD sondern Klarheit gegenüber der
AFD das ist eine rechtsextreme Partei
die davon nicht zu sagen haben heute
sage ich Verantwortung Sigmar Gabriel
hat lange Verantwortung getragen in
diesem Land es gibt noch mal viele die
haben lange Verantwortung getragen die
hätten das alles schon machen können
aber diese Regierung diese
ampelregierung mit Olaf Scholz mit
nancifer die packt jetzt an sowohl bei
der Frage Einwanderung als auch bei der
Frage europäische Außengrenzen als auch
bei der Frage wie können Rückführung
Abschiebung schneller gelingen und wie
kann die Integration verbessert werden
wir tun jetzt das andere reden drüber
und ich habe eine völlige Unterstützung
für das was da gerade passiert und sie
spielen eine wesentliche Rolle als
Parteivorsitzender sie haben gerade
gesagt sie tragen die Verantwortung ich
sozusagen auch für das Profil der Partei
sie haben zusammen mit Saskia esken ein
paar Ideen bei denen sie von der Haltung
des Bundeskanzlers abweichen
industriestrompreis ist ein Beispiele
Mindestlohn von 14 Euro ist ein Beispiel
die Diskussion über die Schuldenbremse
was ich bei Ihnen persönlich aber nicht
wahrnehme ist eine offene Konfrontation
mit Olaf Scholz warum macht sie sich
machen sie sich da so klein als Parteien
Politik muss doch keine Konfrontation
sein warum muss Politik dann immer
Streit Auseinandersetzung drauf und
Konflikt Seite versteht das ist für die
Medien interessant ist aber ich finde
das macht doch Politik nicht interessant
finde wir müssen
in der Ernsthaftigkeit der Lage in der
wir gerade sind und zum Probleme kümmern
die da sind meine Rolle als
Parteivorsitzender mit Saskia esken
zusammen ist eine andere als die des
Bundeskanzlers natürlich denken wir über
die Legislatur hinaus natürlich schärfen
wir das Profil der SPD und ich sage ich
habe überhaupt keine Unterschiedlichkeit
mit dem Bundeskanzler in der Frage dass
die Energiepreise zu hoch sind wir haben
vielleicht unterschiedliche ich will den
industriestrompreis ich kämpfe auch
dafür dass der kommt ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass wir den
industriestrompreis brauchen um die
Wirtschaft hier zu stärken und die
Arbeitsplätze hier zu halten und neue zu
schaffen ich nehme wahr natürlich auch
wie Sie dass die FDP dagegen ist dass
der Bundeskanzler skeptisch ist aber
jetzt geht es darum das zu klären und
ich halte das völlig aus dass es mal
unterschiedliche Meinung gibt das muss
aber kein Streit und erst recht keine
Konfrontation sein jetzt guckt man auf
einen Parteivorsitzende natürlich auch
oft umzuschauen welche Richtung gibt er
vor ich habe jetzt von Stefan weil den
Ministerpräsidenten hier in
Niedersachsen den starken Satz zum
industriestrompreis gelesen das letzte
Wort ist noch nicht gesprochen das hatte
der Welt am Sonntag gerade gesagt das
ist ja sehr viel deutlicher als das was
zum Beispiel machen bei ihnen hat man
manchmal den Eindruck ihre wichtigste
Mission sei den Kanzler zu schützen
jetzt kommt noch ein Zitat von ihnen sie
haben gesagt im Mai es gibt hier einen
Kanzler der wird jetzt wieder gewählt
damit man sie die nächste Bundestagswahl
da tue ich jetzt erstmal alles für heißt
auch wenn die Partei darunter leidet mit
schlechten Umfragewerten stehen sie fest
zum Kanzler und kritisieren die nicht
nein nicht wir unterstütze Olaf Scholz
ich war sein Wahlkampfmanager und ich
bin völlig überzeugt davon dass wir den
richtigen Bundeskanzler haben ich möchte
dass er wieder gewählt wird und dafür
werde ich als Parteivorsitzender auch
Verantwortung tragen und trotzdem und
trotzdem und trotzdem gibt es natürlich
Dinge wo auch wir mal eine
unterschiedliche Meinung haben und wo
ich intern auch dafür kämpfe dafür werbe
wie ich finde mit sehr guten Argumenten
dass wir zum Beispiel den
industriestrompreis bekommen in
Deutschland aber ich habe auch gelernt
als Sozialdemokrat das Zeiten in den
Fraktionen Partei Regierung immer in
einem gegeneinander sind so war das
übrigens damals bei Oskar lafontieren
und Gerhard Schröder mal zwei Namen den
Raum zu werfen das waren keine guten
Zeiten für die SPD das heißt Sie müssen
der Partei keinen eigenständiges Profil
geben
aber das tue ich nicht denn
Auseinandersetzung mit dem Kanzler
sondern das tue ich indem ich über den
Tag hinaus denke bei der Frage wie kann
gute Arbeit Aussehen Stichwort
Mindestlohn bei der Frage wie sieht ein
gerechte Steuersystem aus Stichwort
Ehegattensplitting bei der Frage wie
kann eigentlich die industrielle
Wertschöpfung hier in Deutschland
gehalten worden Stichwort
industriestrompreis da haben wir andere
Position als die Bundesregierung sie
vertritt und da kämpfen wir als SPD für
uns ich will auch sagen es war ja auch
erfolgreich wenn sie auf
koalitionsausschüsse gucken wo wir die
Gas und strompreisbremse durchgesetzt
haben wo wir die übergewinnsteuer
durchgesetzt haben das hätte das alle
ohne sozialdemokratische Parteien nicht
gegeben mich stolz drauf aber wir machen
weiter schlägt sich nicht in guten
Zahlen jeder momentan es gibt eine einen
Politikfeld das ihre
Herzensangelegenheit zu sein das ist die
Sicherheitspolitik da haben sie eine
große Rede gehalten mit der sie
praktisch die SPD neu ausrichten wollen
und auch Bundespolitik neue ausrichten
wollen sie erfordern eine Führungsrolle
Deutschlands in der internationalen
Sicherheitspolitik dazu gehört auch die
Einhaltung des sogenannten 2% Ziels der
NATO also das Deutschland
jährlich mindestens zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes in Verteidigung
investiert jetzt müssen sie gerade
aktuell dabei zusehen wie die
Bundesregierung das klammheimlich
abräumt und es erstmal rausgestrichen
hat aus dem Gesetzentwurf und aufschiebt
wo bleibt denn da ihr Protest es wird
nicht aufgeschoben wir haben ein
Sondervermögen von 100 Milliarden
beschlossen und es gibt eine Klarheit
auch über es gibt einen Klarheit über
ein Beschluss des Deutschen Bundestages
dass wir dass wir in Mittel zwei Prozent
ausgeben werden das wird auch erfüllt
für die nächsten Jahre und das muss
dauerhaft es wird damit jährlich erfüllt
der Verteidigungsminister der finde ich
ein exzellenten Job macht ist jetzt
gerade dabei dass die Mittel endlich
abfließen können dass die
Rüstungsindustrie vorankommt dass die
Verträge geschlossen werden können das
war ja häufig ein Problem haben in den
letzten Jahren das gar nicht genug
produziert werden konnte häufig mussten
Vorgängerinnen Vorgänger von Herrn
Pistorius Geld wieder zurückgeben also
da sind wir dran die
sicherheitspolitische Rolle Deutschlands
ändert sich das sieht auch jeder wir
stehen an der Seite der Ukraine wir sind
der zweitgrößte Waffenlieferant unter
ändert sich gerade die deutsche Rolle
und die zwei Prozent werden eingehalten
es ist eine riesen Veränderung das muss
man zugeben allerdings gibt es ganz
klare Aussagen Olaf Scholz hat in einer
Pressekonferenz am 14.07 noch einmal
gesagt nächstes Jahr also 2024 werden
wir das Ziel das erste Mal erreichen
jetzt haben aber kluge Leute von der
Deutschen Gesellschaft für auswärtige
Politik und vom wirtschaftsinstitut ifo
nachgerechnet und die kommen auf eine
Finanzierungslücke auch fürs nächste
Jahr zwischen sieben Milliarden und 14
Milliarden auch da erreichen sie das
nicht also warum sagt ihr Bundeskanzler
da etwas was nicht eintreten ich kann
diese Zahl nicht bestätigen ich muss mir
das genau angucken welche Zahlen
ausgerechnet wurden was ich weiß ist das
endlich die ganzen rüstungsprozesse die
häufig wahnsinnig lange dauern dass die
beschleunigt werden unter Pistorius dass
wir die 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen
geschlossen haben und ich erwarte auch
dass das Geld jetzt ausgegeben wird
sowohl für die bessere Ausstattung der
Bundeswehr aber auch für die Soldatinnen
und Soldaten dass die geschützt in
Auslandseinsätze gehen wenn es die gibt
dass die gut nachbetreut werden und dass
sie gut ausgebildet werden kommen wir
nochmal zurück zu unserem Anfang die
Situation der SPD ist momentan in
Umfragen nicht gut sie bekommen sehr
schlechte Noten von den Wählerinnen und
Wählern Sie persönlich wollen Ende des
Jahres wieder als Parteivorsitzender
kandidieren und sagen auch sie hoffen
dass sie wieder gewählt werden wenn sie
sich diese schlechte Zwischenbilanz
anschauen wofür wollen sie eigentlich
wieder gewählt werden also ich bin sehr
gerne Vorsitzender der SPD das ist eine
stolze traditionsreiche Partei die
älteste in Europa finde wir haben gerade
eine große Verantwortung wir stellen den
Bundeskanzler und wir stellen viele
Landesregierung wir haben den Kampf
gegen die AFD gegen einen rechtsextreme
Partei die wollen wir klein halten ich
habe es gerade schon gesagt das liegt in
unserer DNA auch wir wollen dieses Land
weiterhin gut durch diese schwere Zeit
bringen mit einer starken
Wirtschaftspolitik in der starken
Sozialpolitik und dafür kämpfe ich und
ähm ich habe eine Sache gelernt als
damal ja Generalsekretär und
zweikampfleiter da habe ich in vielen
Interviews gesessen und musste
rechtfertigen warum wir bei 11 bei 12
bei 13% sind warum wir mit so wenig
Prozenten überhaupt den Anspruch erheben
ein Bundeskanzler stellen zu wollen
vor ihrer sagen wenn es zur
Wahlentscheidung kommt wenn die Leute
entscheiden wer hat eigentlich die
letzten Jahre Verantwortung übernommen
wer hat nicht die lautesten schönsten
Überschriften geschaffen sondern wer hat
konkret für die Menschen was erreicht
dann ist der Blick manchmal ein anderer
als in den Umfragen zwischendurch und
deswegen habe ich ein tiefes Vertrauen
dass wenn wir wirklich gut sind wenn wir
daran arbeiten dass die AFD schlechter
wird wenn wir daran arbeiten dass die
Sozialdemokratie stärker wird bei der
nächsten Bundestagswahl die Ergebnisse
ganz anders sind als derzeitigung Fragen
dass sie wieder spielen setzen auf das
Prinzip Hoffnung und der Parteitag in
dezember wird dann zeigen wie das
ausgeht erstmal vielen Dank für das
Gespräch an dieser Stelle ich danke
das war unser zdf-sommer Interview mit
dem SPD-Vorsitzenden und in der
kommenden Woche treffen ich den FDP-Chef
und Bundesfinanzminister Christian
Lindner ihnen herzlichen Dank fürs
zuschauen und einen schönen Abend
[Musik]